I think the the biggest challenges we
face going forward here is really
communicating our story about what
Atlanta was it's not a new invented name
it's a car British Motor Company with
with good heritage that's been lost in
there in the years Martin corfield
director of a semantic motorcar can play
well Atlanta for me he goes back some
years when I was 17 I actually saw my
first at lunch and load the workshop at
Atlanta motors was established to mostly
in 1936 it was the technically most
advanced British sports car of the year
Atlanta Ridley was a very beautiful well
sought after the lady who was very fast
on her feet by 39 when the wall came
about all efforts were pushed towards
war effort obviously and the committee
didn't continue post Paul and that guys
back in 2006-2007 I recognize this as a
brand obviously was dormant inquired
about securing trademarks purchased
secure those trade pacts up to the
company the company names and of course
I had a car that I could then reverse
engineer to to bring this to the anvil
on tour today I'm currently today the
car sim is the one we got have here with
started 125,000 pounds I think
successful resistors to get some
continuity into the brand we estimate
roughly about 21 cars built originally I
think if we can supersede that I think
that would be a major victory